(pensive music)
- [Narrator] The Tokyo
Olympics made history
even before they began.
They're the first Games
to ever be postponed.
They're also on track
to be the most expensive
Summer Olympics Games ever.
- So when Japan won its bid
to host the Olympics in 2013,
it said that it would
cost around $7.4 billion
but before the pandemic,
the budget had risen
by 70% to $12.6 billion
and that's not really surprising.
- [Narrator] Later,
Japan's Board of Audit said
the cost would exceed $20 billion.
That was before
pandemic-related costs set in.
- So the biggest costs for the Olympics
are the facilities.
The new National Stadium here in Tokyo,
as well as several other large facilities,
aquatic center and others
that have been built
for the Games.
And those cost over $3 billion.
And there was about the same amount
that was spent on
renovating other facilities
to bring them up to
standard for the Games.
So the whole thing, in terms of venues,
was around $7.5 billion.
And the other big cost
is the operational budget
for the Olympics.
It's around $2 billion.
- [Narrator] Almost every Olympics ends up
going over budget.
Bids are usually an optimistic estimate.
- What's different in Tokyo, of course,
is that we've had this one-year delay
and we've also had the pandemic.
So the one-year postponement meant
that there were additional costs incurred
for having to renegotiate contracts
for venues, for having to keep staff on
for an additional period
and various other things,
which added to the overall budget.
- [Narrator] And the public
risk from the pandemic
hasn't gone away,
so the Tokyo Olympics are now proceeding
with COVID countermeasures
that require new costs,
manpower and infrastructure.
Together, the postponement
and COVID measures
will add an estimated $2.5 billion
to the Games' budget
according to event organizers.
On top of those direct costs,
COVID is also taking away much
of Japan's ability to
recoup what they've spent.
- Ticket sales would
be around $800 million
and now they'll be close to zero
because there'll be almost no spectators.
And there'll be almost
no income from visitors.
Of course, athletes and officials
who have come here from overseas
might spend some money
but nothing like the amounts
that the organizers were hoping for
from spectators who
would fill the stadiums,
buy merchandise, spend money
in hotels and restaurants
and that could be, some economists say,
as much as $2 billion and now that's lost.
(lively music)
- [Narrator] Corporate sponsors
have contributed around
$3 billion to the Games
and the IOC has contributed $650 million
to help cover the extra costs
resulting from the pandemic.
Still, that leaves the
bulk of the costs to Japan
with little ability to
recoup in the short term.
But even the most
expensive Summer Olympics
in history pales in comparison
to the overall cost of the pandemic.
- Japan has spent around $800 billon
on stimulus packages, three of them,
because of COVID.
The pandemic is obviously
the most expensive thing
to deal with here.
It's not the Olympics.
But if the Olympics
makes the pandemic worse
and there has to be new stimulus measures,
those could be fair larger
than the actual budget of the Olympics.